you ever had a credit card yep okay
quantitative easing
is when american express visa mastercard
calls you and tells you your credit
limit has gone from five thousand
dollars to fifteen thousand dollars
congratulations to you
quantitative easing is when visa
mastercard calls you and tells you your
credit limit has gone from fifteen
thousand to five thousand dollars
did you understand the difference okay
quantitative tightness quantitative
tightening is 15 becomes five
quantitative easing gets five becomes
fifteen thousand gotcha which means
guess what adam go spend more money yeah
we got your back that's not your money
but we'll let you spend more money wow
quantitative tightening is listen look
we are seeing your spending habits we're
taking ten thousand back your credit is
only five thousand
for the longest time in the since oh
wait whatever the timeline has been with
quantitative easing let's bail all these
big guys out
the more we build people out
the more they've sat around saying oh
it's okay my dad is gonna bail me out oh
my dad is going to bail me out do
whatever you want bro daddy's going to
bail you like 100 my daddy's going to
build me up my daddy's going to bail me
out my dad is going to bail me out
it's time to stop building these bigger
companies uh they're too big to fill
today when we're going to quantitative
tightening
every single month their plan is to take
95 billion dollars of credit off the
table
so what does this mean the government's
gonna say hey mr bank xyz you had this
much now we're lowering it and every
month we're taking 95 billion dollars
off the table okay they're tightening
the economy
we have not experienced this ever
in the history of america we tried
quantitative tightening briefly
in 2008 for maybe a couple months the
market crashed when we tried
quantitative timing no no no no here he
go here put some more money into the
market feed more money into the market
when they did that they bailed out the
guys at the top the guys at the top got
richer middle america the division got
wider now we got people that can't
afford to buy a house that's eight times
their income what the hell are you gonna
do keep increasing the minimum wage
that's not the strategy on what to do
that's not the solution to do that so
we're about to go through quantitative
tightening and i hope this next phase
that we go through
they don't get in the way of these
companies going out of business
the part about capitalism that i love is
the following and this one can we before
we move on from this let me make this
point and you can go to it this is the
part because i didn't understand totally
but yeah go ahead
this is the part the part i love about
capitalism
is is for freedoms
you have the freedom to buy
you have the freedom to sell
we have the freedom to try
and last but not least which some people
don't like we have the freedom to fail
oh i love that isn't that awesome
i didn't come up with it founding
fathers came out don't give me credit
for it no
freedom to try and the freedom to fail
we have to let the too big to fail
fail yes it's that simple and we've
stopped that the last 15 years
you know what's even scarier do you know
in the history that america
do you know in the history of america
okay
since the the great depression do you
even practice that 1850s do you know
what's the longest time america's ever
gone without a recession
when do you think it is
you ready today
14 years
no way yes
we've had recessions every 5 to seven
years and they last six months to 43
months
we have gone 14 years without a
recession
desperately not in a negative way we
desperately need a recession whoa we
desperately need a reception is that
because of um because of uncle trump
no
the economic expansion was 129 months
prior
to
the 129 months of economic expansion
that we had started in oh wait
so that economy the last recession you
got so you got to go from bush to obama
to obama to trump too so but people
think that kovid was a recession it was
just a brief blip on like a drop
back up
because of quantitative easing and money
printing and i bet not to cut you up so
do you think that because this
administration isn't admitting like hey
guys like it's really bad right now it's
happening they're just getting like the
elastic bands this is not a democratic
thing or republican thing
because during this economic expansion
that we've had
we had a year of bush left but when did
obama get elected okay oh wait can you
can you pull up exactly what monta the
128 month economic expansion started i
think it's like sometime i know it so
it's obama obama trump biden
you got
three you got two three democrats terms
is what i'm not saying three democrats
you got three democrats you got one
republican okay and what did all of them
pretty much do let's print to bail out
what month did it start
one month did it start june overnight
is it june of nine mm-hmm okay who was
the president june of all night because
obama took office in january of oh now
so there's elections
the greatest economic expansion
just so you know but yeah started under
obama so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
[Music]